So far we've learned to declare
optionals using question marks, and
we focused on safe ways to unwrap
optionals using question marks and
if let statements.
Now it's time to get
a little reckless and
start working with exclamation points.
Unwrapping optionals with exclamation
points requires a lot more
confidence in your code.
If you try to unwrap a nil value
with an exclamation point, yikes.
To unwrap an optional in
this carefree manner,
place an exclamation
point after the variable.
But if the value inside is nil,
it explodes.
[LAUGH] Okay, nothing explodes,
but it does throw a fatal error.
There is no safe way to unwrap
with an exclamation point.
When you choose to unwrap
with an exclamation point,
you're saying that you want the program
to crash if the value inside is nil.
It communicates to your code readers
that you're confident there will not be
a nil value in the optional.
We can also declare optionals
with an exclamation point,
much the way we did with question marks.
But this optional is different.
It's implicitly unwrapped.
That means that when this optional
is used in an expression,
it will automatically unwrap.
It is an optional, so it can store a
value or nil, but it's as if it's a very
fragile wrapped package that immediately
falls open when it's picked up.
Because we don't unwrap it carefully,
if there's a nil value inside,
bad things can happen.
A fatal error could be thrown.
So in what scenarios would it
be appropriate to use such
a volatile optional?
Let's look at a couple examples.
Let's say we're using our old friend
the Int initializer method and
invoking it on a variable that we're
confident can be converted to an int.
We know this method is going
to return the int 123, so
in this case, unwrapping with
an exclamation point is appropriate.
We know there's little risk
of an error being thrown, so
we can place the exclamation
point after w like this, or
we could unwrap the return
value directly, like this.
In the second case, the value assigned
to w will be a plain old int.
What about declaring implicitly
unwrapped optionals?
When is an appropriate time to be so
bold?
Well, remember the button
property in our view controller?
We know that this button property will
be nil when the view controller's
created, so we know it needs
to have an optional type.
We can also be confident that
this button property will be set
by storyboard.
In that case, it should be okay to
unwrap this property automatically and
declare it with an exclamation point.
It is possible for this to backfire.
Here's what it looks like in an x code
project if we try to use the button but
it hasn't been initialized.
Again, the problem here is that we're
accessing the button in order to get
the title for state but
the button doesn't exist yet.
You can get a fatal error.
This is why one has to be careful and
only try to access an implicitly
unwrapped optional in a case like this
when you know the button will be there.